all right derek first off not a bad way
to spend a tuesday out here beautiful
weather southern highlands just
about talk about being out here today we
absolutely love it here um
at southern highlands you know it was
one of the uh first couple places my
wife and i looked and as soon as we came
out here
obviously we fell in love and my boys
love it they're out here hitting balls
all the time with me and
uh it's it's a good time so yeah it's a
beautiful day here in las vegas
and um you know especially after the
year where it was completely shut down
now that you have a chance to actually
be out in the las vegas community you're
the grand marshal at the
uh speedway i saw you preaching this
beautiful message at the church of las
vegas or l.v
um what's it like to actually start to
make an imprint on this las vegas
community
well you know it's it's who i am on the
inside you know i wanted to
you know be someone that people don't
just see as an idol type of person but
they just see as
someone as a part of their community and
someone that the kids can look up to
someone that does things the right way
and hopefully make an impact you know
in the city that we live in that we call
home and uh it was a crazy 12 months
uh you know i think we've been here a
little over a year now and it was crazy
because
you couldn't really go talk to people
you know everyone was staying away from
each other for
uh for a good reason but now uh
now that vaccines are happening and the
distancing and the numbers are going
down and all those kind of things it's
good that we can come out and
get to know the people of the community
you know the mom and pop shops that have
been here for 30 years you know fit or
more and you know starting to meet
people and impact impact their lives has
been a lot of fun
and you mentioned your wife you guys
have put you know a lot of time and
effort into the valley children's
hospital can you talk about that and how
much that means to both you and your
family and everything
well yeah i mean the people of las vegas
they may not know but we have four
children
our oldest boy dallas had three
surgeries at valley children's hospital
his intestines were all messed up for
lack of a better term
and uh you know he had to have surgeries
there and he almost didn't make it but
we thank god that we had a place like
valley children's that could help save
his life so
any chance we get to raise money or
promote awareness to that place we do
because we were parents
of a child that was a patient there you
know and we know the pain and the
struggle
especially as college kids financially
you know you get freaked out what do we
have what are we going to do you know
things that you don't even know the
answers to and so we just try and ease
that burden
as best as we can for the for the
parents and the and really the kids that
are going through what they're going
through there
can you mention your kids um how's being
a girl dad we asked you this way back
um now you got four months under your
belt what's it like i mean i could see
your face lit up so there you go
yeah yeah she can she can do no wrong
you know my boys come in the room it's
like what's up bro they're like saying
what's up dad you know
and then when she comes in the room she
just lights it up you know her face is
so beautiful you know she's so peaceful
she's so joyful she uh
she brings so much joy to our family you
know and at any moment you walk into our
house one of my boys
if not heather i are holding her you
know they just they absolutely
love her and uh so do i so it's been a
lot of fun that's awesome and a couple
more for you i promise um
you know we mentioned girl dad obviously
that that phrase was kind of coined
because of kobe i know you're a huge
kobe fan he was a fan of the wnba
obviously mark davis bought the aces how
much do you watch the wnba i know he
referred to the aces
and the raiders as brothers and sisters
now how cool is that to kind of have
the aces as quote-unquote your sisters
yeah it's pretty cool you know and it
what's what's nice about being a girl
dad now is what you're starting to see
is the communication of you know women's
sports
is is becoming more and more popular you
know there's starting to be more
highlights on tv there's starting to be
more
communication about it and that's
exciting for my daughter you know if
that's what she wants to do you know
i know it's exciting for some of my
nieces that uh that play basketball one
plays softball and basketball and
runs track plays golf you know and the
fact that um
you know they're going to get a great
opportunity now to be able to do those
things and hopefully do them at a
college or professional level
it's exciting for me you know so uh
hopefully hopefully when my when my
little girl grows up she'll be able to
go shoot some hoops over there and have
some fun with that but uh yeah it's very
exciting
no football questions i was told but
just fans the potential of fans in the
stands next year
how exciting is that especially after
the season i mean brand new stadium no
fans unfortunately but
this year something to look forward to
for sure yeah everyone kept telling me
uh when we moved here how awesome the
knights games were you know and how
rowdy that environment was
and i told him i was like you know i bet
it was but just wait till these raider
fans show up
and and this city catches that
atmosphere as well so
as great as this city is and how awesome
they've been for the nights i think it's
going to go to another level
um for our raiders because i've seen it
firsthand there's nothing like it
i've been here this will be my eighth
year with the team and
i won't play for anybody else you know
it's just that special to me so
i'm very excited to finally get to play
in front of the people i've gotten to
meet around town
i mean literally everybody i've met like
man we have tickets i'm like i can't
wait for you to come to a game it'll be
so fun so
uh we need that home field event so las
vegas get ready you know we're going to
need you
to win this thing today i heard your
golf game's not too shabby yeah we
better win
yeah man renfro we got we got big plans
so we better win this thing